YOU KNOW HE'S GOING TO BE FIRED
UP AND HE WAS REALLY SKATING AS
HEWER PLAY GOAL IN ONE OF
THEIR PAST EIGHT ROAD GAMES.
POWER PLAY GOAL, AND SEBASTIAN
AHO CONTINUING ON FROM HIS LAST
THERE AHO WINS THE PUCK BATTLE
WIT TO KEEP THE
PUCK IN THE ZONE.
REAL SHARP ANGLE.
HE NEVER LOOKS ATDAVID, HYMANO .
ONE TIMER.
DOORSTEP.
>> Hanaryan: ZACK KASSIAN COMING
IN, AND SHOTS ON NET
IN THE FIRST ALMOST 14 MINUTES
BEFORE THIS SHIFT RIGHT HER ON
ICE.
THIS IS CONNOR McDAVID, PARDON
SO MANY TIMES FOR CONNOR
McDAVID.T I AGREE WITH THEM, TH
TWO GAMES HAVE BEEN THE TYPES O.
TROCHECK AND SVECHNIKOV
SWITCHING SPOTS, SVECHNIKOV
MOVING TO THE FRONT, KOSKINEN
TROCHECK, AND FAST JUST CAN'T
KNOCKED OFF HIS STICK. GOES
HE'S GOING TO GET IT RIGHT  TO H
CROSSES THE BLUE LINE.
FLIPS THE PUCK HIGH.
HE'S TRYING TO P GOAL THAT
REALLY CAN DEFLATE YOUR TEAM
WHEN YOU'RE IN TH
[ Horn ]
THE EDMONTON OILERS ARE FINALLY
ON THE BOARD IN THIS ONE-HOPKINF
SPEED, HAS ALWAYS THE BLOCKER.
HE MAKES A BIG HYMAN.
I THINK HE MIGHT HAVE HIT HIS
MIDDLE, AIS IS A
DENIED.
GIVE CAME
BACK EARLIER THIS WEEK.
IT'S A CAAL.
HE JUST FUNNELS TO THE FRONT OF
THE NEOVE THROUGH
THE NEUTRAL ZONE, HERE'S HE  AGE
HURRICANES.T TAKESCHANCE,
ZACH HYMAN, HE'S GOING TO BE
THINKING ABOUT THAT ONE.
HERE'S THAT CHANCE.
AND TAKE A TWO-GOAL LN UNTIMELY
MOVES UP A PASS, AND WHAT A SAVE
BY FREDDY ANDERSEN!UL PASS BY
McDAVID.
PUTS IT RIGHT THROUGH SLAVIN.
ATTEMPTED ONCE, STAYS WITH IT, .
[ Cheers and Applause ]
DID IT GOOES OFF
THE LEFT PAD AND COMES BACK OUT
WHERE ANDERSEN IS ABLE TO